so it's last week of scroll through
September all the weeks this has
definitely been the easiest that is
mainly because I think of fully detached
from wanting to stay within the loop
with everything I've been anticipating
Monday morning when I can actually go
back online and it's a bit of
trepidation in there because I don't
know whether there's many messages what
I've missed whether I'm going to catch
up on it all or whether and I'm just
going to have to write off the last
month and miss what people have been
saying I had some very strong ideas
check Facebook among other things that I
shouldn't be checked and that I don't
really have any need to check it with
some emotion craving but actually the
opportunity to not check it because I'm
on the challenge and the opportunity to
face those cravings and those urges and
deal with that restlessness rather than
just giving in to it has been really
valuable this month I've learned that
there's no need to be going on snapchat
Instagram until 3 o'clock in the morning
because you're not actually going to
miss anything and I've learned that it's
not as important and it's just time
consuming and it's like social media is
a habit when I turn my devices back on
tomorrow I'm going to respect the amount
of time that I actually spend looking at
because having done the exercise I know
that my screen time most of which was
tied up with social media that was
wasted I spend most of my time on social
media when actually look stressed and if
there's anything that you knew that
stresses me out a bit or just anything I
would find myself wanting to go on one
of the apps just to scroll and I think
just to like not not think about
anything